my whole life changed with five simple
words delivered casually by a relative
at a party you know you're autistic
right
initially I rejected the idea I was 30
and my knowledge of autism was based on
TV caricatures and digs from people who
suggested anyone behaving poorly must be
on the Spectrum
I thought autistic people were math
Wizards who lacked empathy and loved
trains
of course there's no one way to be
autistic and autism can present quite
differently in different people
I'm a loudmouth creative with an
overactive empathy chip who can barely
add two digits together
and I couldn't care less about trains
my story is more common than you'd think
growing up my autistic meltdowns a
totally involuntary response to
emotional or physical overload were
dismissed as attention seeking
this was really confusing and scary as I
came to believe I was somehow acting out
on purpose
add to that sensory sensitivities making
many lights noises smells textures and
tastes overwhelming and painful as well
as severe aversions to almost all food
and spoiled brat was added to the charge
sheet
my tendency to Simply blurt out
uncomfortable truths was misinterpreted
by others as manipulative
it seemed that everything I did was
misunderstood and so I began to over
explain myself a trait others found
annoying
by the time I was seven my self-esteem
began to plummet
I tried to hide my difficulties and
differences by disguising my obsessive
interests or choosing similar ones to
the other girls like boy bands for
example in my case Hanson even if I
never did marry Zach this is called
masking and it's something many autistic
girls do to try to blend in
unfortunately the long-term effects of
masking can cause mental health issues
and autistic burnout and experience lots
of autistic people can relate to where
our difficulties are suddenly magnified
and it becomes impossible to participate
in the world
autism is often presented as an illness
to be cured when in fact it's just a
different way of experiencing the world
while it comes with its downsides it
also has benefits
contrary to stereotypes autistic people
can be creative emotional and highly
empathetic kind while saying exactly
what we mean
I care deeply about social justice I
connect with animals I get Untold Joy
from my intense interests and when my
sensory sensitivities are focused on
positive experiences like music it can
be wonderful
[Music]
around one in a hundred people in the UK
are thought to be autistic with three
times as many boys as girls being
diagnosed like many areas of medical
research women are underrepresented in
studies and many of the diagnostic
criteria for autism were developed with
men in mind
over the past decade our understanding
of how autism can manifest differently
in girls and women and also how our
autistic behaviors can be interpreted
differently has changed but research
still has a long way to go
until I was diagnosed as autistic I
thought I was a broken terrible person
my diagnosis gave me a framework to
explain my experience to loved ones and
the wider world
meeting other autistic people gave me
permission to understand and even begin
to like myself
being autistic isn't all roses and
sunshine like anything it comes with its
pros and cons some people see autism as
an illness whilst others call it a
superpower
to me it's neither it's simply the
blueprint for who I am and to cure me of
my autism would be to cure me of myself
My Hope Is that Society comes to better
understand the autistic experience so
that future generations of women are
able to be diagnosed at an earlier age
that way they can be given the support
they need to thrive have self-confidence
and relate to the World on their own
terms as their unique brilliant autistic
selves
[Music]
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
Subscribe button and click the Bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video